he was at the ace eddie awards on friday
night the event honors the editors of
the greatest TV shows and movies of the
year including the dynamic duo behind
star wars the force awakens what was
your reaction when JJ called you up and
said hey guys guess what we're working
on starving it was like really fer did
we just to Star Trek reduce we actually
take place star trackers are welcome we
were over the moon very happy he didn't
really call us either we were all
working on structure guided darkness so
he can vote to vote for both of us you
walk into the room and said ok I said
yes for Star Wars and just be there and
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
raise force vision includes veteran
voices like Alec Guinness Ewan McGregor
and Frank Oz but one was almost actually
in the movie it's so came together I it
was like magic literally like I can't
believe it and you know there's Yoda's
voice in as well so we
it was at one point we're actually
thinking of having Yoda in the film and
then we decided not to and then but we
did use Frank Oz came in for day and did
a whole bunch of Yoda and he was over
the moon to do it and we were tickled
pink